prescription drug monitoring programs
are very powerful databases that
currently 49 states have implemented
it's a pretty new thing they've just
started in the past maybe five years or
so for most states although a handful of
states have had them for a couple of
decades the new thing about this is that
they're often web-based so as an
emergency physician I can see a patient
if I'm considering giving them a
medication like an opioid I can log on
to a state database and what it does is
it tells me all of the controlled
substance prescriptions those are
medications like benzodiazepines for
anxiety or pain medications like opioids
tells me every single prescription
they've had in the state and often in
surrounding states now as well too
this has been a game changer for us
there's so called doctor shopping where
patients go from hospital to hospital we
don't like that term but that's often
frequently what it's called and we've
seen a market decrease in that because
of the existence of prescription drug
monitoring programs and the reason is
that it's it becomes difficult to to
have multiple prescribers for your
medications so patients that go from
from a merchants department to emergency
department and get different
prescriptions now now have difficulty
with that frankly and that's that's
that's a good thing it's gotten to the
point where initially we were really
advocating for their for them to be
implemented and now the government has
realized how powerful these are and in
many states it's actually mandated so in
in the state of Massachusetts for
example if I want to prescribe a
prescription if I want to prescribe an
opioid I have to access the state
prescription drug monitoring program at
that point it's forced us to use it it's
it it's actually entered our workflow
which is a very good thing and probably
the most powerful part about this is
that if I'm seeing a patient that has a
profile that has lots of prescriptions
from lots of different providers I print
that out and I bring it to the bedside
and it starts a conversation why why do
you have so many providers why are you
getting so many prescriptions and that
can be a very powerful teachable moment
I think pharmacists play a very big role
number one because we're responsible for
dispensing the opioids so the opioids
have to come from somewhere and although
many of them are
found throughout a prescription usually
they are obtained by someone who had a
prescription from their doctor and they
got it at a pharmacy so it's our job as
pharmacists to make sure that every
prescription we fill is for a legitimate
medical purpose and it's written by a
doctor that is practicing within their
scope and so it is our job to prevent
any prescriptions being filled that
shouldn't basically having patients who
are in pain that need the medication get
it and the other patients that are
potentially abusing the drug or selling
it hopefully they they wouldn't be
getting it from the pharmacy we also
help avoid the opioid crisis by
maintaining an accurate inventory in the
pharmacy make sure there's no diversion
or stealing as you would call it and if
anyone calls and they ask hey how much
oxycodone do you have we don't give them
that information over the phone we keep
very strict inventory so there's many
ways including making sure that we check
the prescription monitoring program and
communicating with doctors if there's
any patient that's trying to fill
prescriptions early or anything that
seems out of the ordinary so there's
many ways that I feel that we can help
continue to decrease the crisis
sometimes we're faced with a situation
in the pharmacy where we do not fill an
opioid medication when the patient
brings the prescription even though the
doctor wrote it there's several reasons
that this may occur one of the most
common reasons is that it's too soon to
fill it we have a very strict policy as
far as when you can fill your controlled
substances to avoid anybody getting
early refills so typically if you filled
your prescription for your controlled
substance 30 days ago basically we would
never fill it sooner than 28 days from
that time so we have to make sure not to
fill any prescriptions
that are controlled Stubbs substances
and that's the number one reason why we
would deny a patient filling a
medication for a controlled substance
other reasons that we might not fill a
prescription is because of other red
flags that we see in their profile they
don't want to fill it through their
insurance for example which is a red
flag because everybody has insurance
it's required and basically if they're
saying I don't want to pay for it with
my insurance they're trying to avoid us
seeing them getting another prescription
most likely somewhere else where it did
go through the insurance so in this case
they're usually pharmacy shopping or
doctor shopping and in this case it's
easy now for us to check on the
prescription monitoring program online
and see where they filled their last
prescription how many they got are they
due for a refill it's our job basically
to make sure that if you have pain
medication you get it when you're due to
fill it not too soon not before it's due
but you should be taking it as
prescribed and in that case you
shouldn't need to get it early so if a
patient tells me that they're out
because they were taking it differently
than what the label said that concerns
me and I immediately contact the doctor
we we play a big role in keeping the
doctor in the loop because a lot of
information comes from the patient when
they're trying to get a prescription and
it's for instance too soon to be filled
we can also not fill a prescription if
after we talked to the doctor they say
hey I didn't know that they had this
other prescription they never told me
cancel the prescription so sometimes the
doctors do in fact cancel the
prescriptions that they already wrote
once they're informed about the other
prescriptions that they got these days
that's mostly avoided because they've
already seen before they wrote the
prescription by logging into the
prescription monitoring program what
they've got in the last time they got it
so that issue doesn't really fall in the
pharmacists anymore but sometimes you
know foster the cracks and a patient is
using more than one doctor and maybe
they're outside of the partners Network
and that's the situation where
you know we don't feel comfortable
filling the prescription but we keep the
doctor in the loop as well the med safe
program is basically a disposal unit
that sits outside the pharmacy at Mass
General and it allows patients at any
time of day to come and drop off their
medications whether it has a label on it
or it doesn't have a label they're not
sure what it is it doesn't matter as
long as it's not a syringe any type of
tablet at all can be disposed here and
it just gets incinerated and it's safely
handled by our employees at in the
pharmacy we just dispose of the box and
then the Med safe company incinerates it
so they don't need to worry about their
personal information being anywhere so
it's very safe and here at Mass General
it's so popular that we have to change
out the the unit about once a week so
there's a lot of medications out there
that are being dropped off so it's been
a very effective form of a drug
take-back every week we have to replace
the disposal unit and we send back about
50 pounds worth of drugs back to the
company to be incinerated just to give
you an idea of how many drugs are
actually dropped off every week here at
the hospital
it's it's a very significant amount and
it decreases the number of tablets that
are out on the in people's homes and
available for basically use and it could
be controls and non controls so it's not
just controlled substances that are
going in there it's it's any type of old
expired unused medication